[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality host of the
dr john deloney show best-selling author
and host and uh author of the brand new
book that is in pre-sale own your past
change your future he's my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
relationships your boundaries your
mental health your work your career and
your money it's all right here it's a
free call some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five
two two five steven starts off this hour
in mobile alabama hi steven welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
i just wanted to run a question by my
wife and i bought a residential lot
little over a year ago to build on
and uh due to some
how the building
industry is going the builder seemed
like they wanted to get out of it so
lo and behold we're in another house now
and we've got that lot she's got a
little over 40 000 in student debt
so just didn't know if it's something we
should rush to sell we've had it on the
market but not too much interest
should we lower the price to try to sell
it and put that toward the debt quicker
or just kind of
route it out
so you are trying to sell it the only
question is how motivated you should be
yes okay
all right what's it on the market for
well for 20 right now what'd you pay for
it
we paid 11. i put probably 3 500 into uh
work on it before we
terminated the contract what's the work
uh just some excavation trees and
you know okay getting it ready to so you
got 15 you got 15 or so in it give or
take right
yes sir all right
and you're out on the market for 20 for
how long
a little over 150 days
okay
well it's a fairly hot real estate
market it hasn't sold
um i guess you're not desperate i don't
need to give it away but i'd probably
drop it to something and try a little
dollar 99 psychology to see if we can
get it to move have you got a bad
realtor
well i don't think so i'm not sure
really we've used her for a few things
before and seems to do a good job but uh
it may not be anything she's in a rush
for just because the price price is
twenty thousand dollars or she didn't
make anything yeah
um
you know you might i tell you what you
may i would uh do a little shopping hit
our elp our endorsed local provider
for real estate in the area a couple of
them and interview them just call them
on the phone and just go hey i've got
this lot it's been on the market pull it
up on mls tell me what your thoughts are
why it hasn't sold and you don't even
have to you don't even have i'm not
going to take up your time with meeting
a phone call at work and just take up a
little bit of gather a little intel
about what's going on because i mean
for somebody call me up and say any
piece of real estate has said 150 days
in this white hot real estate market
makes bells go off in my head
something's wrong
you're pro your price is way off or your
realtor's lazy or
this is a horrible piece of ground or i
don't know that's what i'm wondering is
it i mean i've seen people pay double of
what something was originally listed for
did
did your builder walk away because the
ground is not good
it there's a slope to it it's uh we
hadn't got it flat yet he walked away
because work wasn't done yet and we
spoke to some other builders and their
costs were above what we were willing to
pay
so so did you
turn people did you buy a new house or
are you renting right now and here's
what i'm asking
okay so you're you're done you're where
you're going to be you're not going to
build a house anymore
well i'm dropping the price i'm dropping
the price and i'm probably changing real
estate agents yeah but i'm not dropping
it to 14 nine i'm dropping it to 19 nine
or eighteen nine or something just try
to give it a little refresh
give it a little give it a little z a
little shock there and let's get it
moving something like that um
because it hadn't sold and i there's
that you know
something wrong it sounds weird yeah
everything everybody you talk to real
estate's you know depending on and
mobile is no exception mobile's a hot
market too so but i don't know where you
are i don't know if you're out in the
country somewhere or if it's bad topo on
this thing it's full of rock i don't
know what it is i mean i i've i've got a
lot or two that look like their rock
farm
i'm in tennessee looks like we're gonna
have a good crop
spring we're gonna harvest those things
i'm just saying i mean wow it's uh but
you know sometimes you get into that and
the building costs to put a pro you know
to
you know you're not you're not exactly
excavating you're more like dynamiting
you know to get to get ready yeah and
that sometimes is what we get into like
in tennessee i doubt in mobile you're
probably down the coast you probably not
got that type of soil issue but you
could be all kinds of different things
like that sean's with us sean is in west
palm beach florida hey sean what's up
hi there uh my wife and i just
adopted our little girl from india wow
and
thanks and we have a question as far as
where to put that doc adoption tax
credit what to use it with
and
we i had two ideas we're on baby steps
four five and six so i was thinking
about putting our
traditional ira to convert it to a roth
there's about 65 000 in that
which would eat up that 14
300 um credit or we would just adjust my
withholding and put it put more in the
house
um no i i would not convert stuff to
roth while you still have house debt
okay because in effect you're borrowing
on your house to do the conversion
right okay so yeah i'm gonna go ahead
and uh make sure babe you got uh baby
step five you got good 529 going for the
kiddo
we're doing that as well yep i mean you
could drop some money into that
okay like heavy like headed hard because
if you take a brand new baby and drop
five grand in there it's going to turn
into a lot of money in 18 years
that's good
all right well thank you so much so i
might do some of that maybe five there
and or ten there and then the rest of it
on the house but no i'm not gonna do the
roth conversion
i didn't realize the tax credit was so
so extensive that's
must be i don't i don't know it's new
yeah that that's large yeah i didn't
think i was going to hear that number
i'm like you oh yeah 14 grand huh
somehow i had 3 500 bucks in my head
that's what i was thinking
um
somewhere it must it may have something
to do with um
the situation around the adoption ah
sometimes that'll uh change things a
little bit but i don't know you got me
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thanks for
joining us dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today over the
last 30 years we've walked with tens of
thousands no millions of families to
help them overcome their financial
stress but there's all kinds of stress
out there
and that is what dr deloney is
addressing in his new book called own
your past change your future it's
available for pre-order it's selling
really good that's good man
really good it's like really exciting
it's good yeah this is great and the
book is all about changing your story
that's right changing
changing what happened owning what
happened you can't change what happened
owning what happened and then deciding
what am i going to do next
you got to reach a point you're not
living in the past and what happened all
the time and let that be your definition
we don't often think we're living in the
past but our body sure does and it's
syncing it all up together and playing
the tapes over and over there you go
there you go mental health matters hey
uh you get a free month of one-on-one
therapy with the folks over at better
health you get the audio book and the
e-book all in the pre-order at 20
at dave ramsey i'm sorry ramsey
solutions dot com
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america as we talk about your
relationships your mental health your
money your career it's all on the line
right here triple eight eight two five
five two two five mike is in canada hey
mike welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave happy to be here thanks for
having me sure man what's up
uh so i recently doubled my income i
used to make uh 40 000 a year now making
80 000 gross good for you and uh
i'm starting to pay off my debt and i
had a question so i know like i'm
currently in step two i know you need to
the destiny ball you need to uh pay the
smallest the largest regardless of
interest but have a credit card put like
an equal payment plan so there's
absolutely no interest on it and it's
just equalized there's like a year and a
half left in babies about 18 months
so i was wondering should i pay that off
immediately it's only about two grand
but i also have like the second bigger
loan is like a family loan for six grand
so which one should i prioritize should
i keep making the equal payments or
should i just
squash that debt out the 2k
okay you just told me you list your
payments smallest to largest you pay
minimum payments on everything but the
smallest
and you put all the money on the
smallest until it's gone regardless of
interest
you just told me that you take a cycle
off you just told me that it feels
better to just pay off your siblings
because like that's the sixth grand
there's a family going on right now
are they in trouble
uh no they're just nagging about it i'm
like i just want to pay it off are you
paying them payments as agreed
no no
you're not paying them anything i'm just
gonna
no it's just like okay just paid on lump
i'm sorry
d do you just wanted to pay the lump sum
do you have six grand to pay him a lump
sum
uh no like like i'm i'm in maybe step
two so all i have like in my pockets for
like 1200 so
what was the loan for
uh it's uh well i actually have two
family loans for student debt so i
didn't really go through a bank or i
just borrowed from family members so
i've got 30 grand in total
all to both siblings
you have 30 grand or three grand
i've got
six grand for one sibling 24 for the
other
30 in total and the six grand is the
squeaky wheel
yes okay well you'll get to them when
you get to them yeah
two grams first knock it out all right
then and then get to the sibling because
i take it you're paying them no payments
now and when you finish off this credit
card like this month next month you're
gonna start sending them what two
thousand dollars a month or a thousand
dollars a month what are you gonna send
them
uh well they live in a different
countryside i'm because i'm a cheap
bastard i'm like okay i'll just save up
and pay him a lump to avoid the wiring
fees because she's in germany on canada
wiring fees are not that high
yeah your avoidance here
yeah i'm just avoiding it i guess yeah
and here's what i do i'd sit down i'd
call my sibling and say
i'm sorry i've left you hanging here
here's what i'm gonna do here's my plan
i'm gonna pay you this much every month
for this ex time and then we're gonna
get done with this thing
all the avoidance and they all just let
it pile up yeah if i was them i'd be
house on you too because it sounds like
you're just avoiding it all
make a plan with them as though they're
a creditor right yeah
and so and it's been a while how long
have they have you had this
money uh about a year and a half now
yeah okay and you didn't have good clear
terms and agreement on when you were
going to pay back or how you were going
to pay it back so they made up one
scenario in their head you made up
another scenario in your head and so now
we're pissed about this scenario that
doesn't even exist
so the best thing to do is get it off
the books as fast as you can in the
meantime call now how much can you put
on debt with 80 000 a year how much can
you put on debt a month
if i like don't go out or don't do
anything yeah like what we tell you to
do yes don't go out
what would it be
i'll try not to you know no you don't
have to try
don't do it
yeah didn't you watch star wars one
there is no try just do it
so
how much
all right
how much
i can put down i will put down 25 until
i pay off my debt so about that twenty
five hundred dollars hey like so so that
pays off the credit card this month next
month you're gonna send twenty five
hundred dollars the next month you're
going to send 2 500
the next month you're going to pay that
sibling off and if you call them and
tell them or send them an email that
that's what's going to occur they're
going to stop whining if you follow
through on that
and
mike i'm gonna change your life are you
ready
yes okay listen to me this is this is
the way you live this is a microcosm of
your life and it stops today
you have almost fractured family
relationships
over a problem that could be solved in
90 days
that's ridiculous because you're
circling around and you're like i don't
know
solve the problem in 90 days
most of our health problems can be
solved in 90 days a great number of our
mental health challenges can be solved
in 90 days relationships can be healed
tonight if someone will just go do it oh
goose if i don't go out anymore is that
worth your sister
get done with it man what dinner is
worth your sister right or who's to my
friends get it paid off and never ever
ever
not get something knocked out that's
gonna take 90 days of hard work good
grief okay that's it i'm done now we're
good oh yeah i'm glad you feel better
i'm done now geez
but yeah that's exactly right so star
wars one was
there is no try was yoda double shot in
one i think it was one or two i don't i
don't know i'm looking at james james
james sorry i'm not a star wars star
wars geek
oh
you look like he tells luke to do this
thing and they're in a swamp and he's
like lifting the oh man
we've said some things on the show that
gets the the hate mail and the cards and
letters but we're about to get them yeah
we're gonna get now we got a whole two
and he said i'm getting a vote for two
i'll try to lift it i'm getting a vote
for two from the from the lobby he said
there's gotta vote for two all right
well but uh
yeah i'm cause i'm thinking one didn't
have that much pithiness in it
um i could be wrong but it's um
yeah i mean it's so old episode five if
you're a true nerd it was so old i was a
teenager okay that's how old one is
all right
that's
freaking oh you all went to the theater
in your covered wagon horror picture
show and star wars like a brand new
cold it was
oh man so here's the thing
i think that brings up a good point
though um
our our friend our mutual friend james
cloyer that wrote the book atomic habits
um he talks about and craig groschel was
talking about this another friend in his
leadership podcast the other day um
and he's speaking at the smart
conference in the fall craig is but this
idea that um
you have to be careful
biblically and psychologically what
comes out of your mouth
i'll try yep no you're not a person who
is trying to quit smoking you're a
person who used to smoke that's right
that's a whole different set of phrasing
activate your brain
your spirit in a whole different way
that's right i am getting out of debt
and so during this time
i'm going to list the debts smallest to
largest i'm going to pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one i'm going to attack the little one
with a vengeance i'm not going to see
the inside of a restaurant during this
period of time unless i'm working there
as my extra job
and i'm not going on vacation during
this time there is no try that's exactly
right you you i use you create a new
identity i'm a person who used to
struggle with money i don't anymore
right i'm a steward of my money period
yeah and that that is the frame with
which i decide am i going to go out math
used to intimidate me it doesn't anymore
correct i'm a person i'm a person who
does the math because it's causing me to
win at my life and oh by the way the
math is the fifth grade level
needed to build wealth you don't have to
have a calculus degree to build wealth
that's right you do not have to pass
trigonometry or geometry you don't have
to spell pythagorean theorem to become
wealthy all you've got to do is one you
don't even have to be really good at
multiplication right just long division
and
addition and a little subtraction
it's not that hard but it's but what
happens is our brains tell us this stuff
over and over and over i was the kid who
struggled in math class so i'm not good
at money or some or your mom told you
we're just not good at math in the in
the
ramsey family is not good at math or the
ramsey family's always good at math and
you took that on as an identity right
this is an identity change that's what
claire's talking about right and that's
what craig's talking about you change
your identity you go this is who i am
i'm a joyful happy
really good at math person i'm a guy
that takes hey i used to fight it i got
to go work out i got to go to work out
nope nope i'm a guy who takes care of my
body and that will result well
that's right there's a cause and effect
here that's right
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage paul and kathy are with us
hey guys how are you hey dave we're
great great welcome where do you guys
live
charlotte oh welcome to nashville cool
glad to be here it's a fun drive over
pretty time of year to do that we flew
oh well that's even better
there's just that okay
all right good so how much debt have you
two paid off
well we had about 173 000.
and how long did that take you took us
five years and four months five years
and four months and your range of income
during that time
started out around 105 and uh it's up
about 150 right now cool what do y'all
do for a living i'm a computer software
consultant and i take care of a couple
of little girls that's perfect
as it should be okay good so what kind
of debt was the 173 000 we had about 9
000 left on old business debt we had a
house flipping business that my son and
i started
we were
trying to pay that off before we got
into financial peace
and then 164 000 was on a mortgage paid
off your house yes looking at
yeah very cool congratulations i'm about
to retire and uh
we had a goal of getting me out getting
us out of that mortgage before i retired
there you go there you go i'll be 65 in
november changes everything that's
awesome how long you all been married
38 years 38 years all right very good
yeah very good he looks at her as he
answers and she wasn't sure
that was great i like that i like that
star dude
yes it seems like just yesterday
22 minutes too late 22 minutes
22 minutes i love it i love it way to go
you guys have you ever been debt-free
since you've been married
oh heck no no not until now
although
we did pay off a house back in 1999 2000
when i hit it big with stock options
then i got really stupid after that and
that's when the flipping houses started
yeah well you got cocky took out an
equity loan for a hundred grand yeah i
was put it in the stock market did a
bunch of crazy things yeah
man you did it all
just bring it
how long they've been married but she
remembers what he did when he was stupid
with his money i like it
for all that pain well way to go you
guys all right tell us your story what
happened five years ago started this so
financial peace university i said to
kathy i said yeah what i'm doing isn't
going to work for our retirement we've
got to do something different please
come to financial peace with me
and i kind of dragged her along that
first day the first night
i wonder why
you know another scheme another scheme
yes
and uh
you know it was great when we left that
first night i was more pumped than he
was yeah sure yeah and we can we cut up
our 13 credit cards that first night oh
well within a couple weeks a couple
weeks wow good for you yeah yeah your
wallet is thinner now you don't have to
go the chiropractor from your back being
out of alignment
we've led fpu probably a half dozen
times well thank you yes thank you thank
you at your local church yes what's the
church we're catholics we uh we're in a
couple different parishes wonderful
saint mark's in huntersville very cool
well thank you very very much we're
honored to have you thank you very
rewarding we also got onto the dave
ramsey website and when we moved to
charlotte and looked up and endorsed
local provider
hooked up with this young guy 27 years
old at the time brian wheeler
he really helped us yeah helped us a lot
let me tell you how cool his smart
wrestler pro is he came with him he flew
up here to do the debt freeze
that's a pretty cool financial advisor
it comes with you to do your debt most
of y'all's financial advisors won't
return your phone calls
and he comes from charlotte's to do the
debt for him with you what it's a
beautiful steak dinner last night wow
well you're a success story or one of
them yeah yeah way to go you guys yeah
so proud of you we're excited so how
does it feel to not have a mortgage yeah
it feels fantastic oh man what a great
feeling that is
what does it feel like it sounds like
you got more than just your your money
back it sounds like you
kathy you talking about oh here's
another scheme here's another dog and
pony show that's what sharon always said
she's always telling me you're scheming
and scamming there you go right but it
sounds like you got
trust back with one another tell us
about that
getting on the same page just yeah being
on the same page and i really trust him
now i mean
in the years back i would say
we're just not going to make it yeah and
but then we did and we have you to thank
dave i mean that that first that first
meeting just changed our lives yeah
and you know we were in our 50s close to
60
and uh we didn't know if we had enough
time yeah you know a lot of a lot of the
people that are scary a lot of people
that attend fpu
older people like us
are can we actually do it yeah yeah paul
where there's a will there's a way paul
what would you tell the guy who is
the casual listener to have a guy be 60
years old and say
the trajectory i'm on is i'm going to
crash this car i got to do something
different that takes a lot of humility
to do that and a lot of men in your
situation financial and otherwise making
good money you've been ups and down
don't have the courage to say that out
loud what would you tell them
just got to be true to yourself
you know men put on facades all the time
you know we got we got egos and we don't
like to be vulnerable yeah but uh when
you're true to yourself
you're vulnerable true to your wife let
her let her know what's actually going
on
only good things can happen after that
that's so good man
touchdown yeah touchdown
you're a brave good man thank you it's
awesome
what was the hardest part of this for
y'all
what do you think
i'm doing the budget
[Laughter]
nerd in the meeting
oh oh no in the beginning
yeah i had spreadsheets man
[Laughter]
he still does
oh he's got bar graphs
all the buttons work right oh great man
that's great yeah that's good well you
know
we're so honored that uh we get to be
part of your story because you got an
incredible story i'm so proud of you
very very well done when you're teaching
the class and somebody's sitting there
what do you tell them the main thing
they have to do if they want to get out
of debt is
what i tell them is the budget is super
critical you know you got to make sure
that your
every dollar has a name like what you
say
and uh
you got to get on the same page with
your spouse i mean so many of them
only one couple one of the couple comes
and it's so hard to do it with when when
that's the way it works you've got to
get on the same page
budget helps and just be honest with
yourselves try to set goals together
that's really key that's powerful
a lot of wisdom so we can do now man
well i'm going to retire at the end of
this year
and we're going to do a lot of traveling
all right
have you had that first paycheck deposit
where you don't have a mortgage payment
oh yeah we got out of that we made the
last payment in august so okay tell us
tell us tell the listener what that
feels like when that check deposits and
it's all yours
i tell you it is so freeing it is so
freeing to know that uh you don't owe a
dime to anybody else and unless you get
stupid
it's going to be that way for the rest
of your life
[Laughter]
don't be duct tape
you two are awesome we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too i'm sure you're
there or almost there already it's
definitely the next chapter in your
story congratulations we're so proud of
you copy of the total money makeover to
uh for you to give away and stir up a
ruckus with somebody else and get them
started thank you for leading financial
peace and for going through it uh we're
so honored to talk to you guys you're
you're you're amazing
thank you thank you one thing i just
want to tell you that
your phrase it's not good enough that
was the best thing for me we've used it
several times yes
several times it's not good enough
that's powerful yeah the old negotiating
lesson i haven't heard that line back in
the day it's a negotiating phrase oh
beware lesson there yeah yeah yeah so
that's a couple of versions back yeah
the last last car we bought was 75 100
dollar bills in my pocket
that's not good enough and i got it at
500 on your list
i like it all right paul and kathy count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
we're dead free
and everything
those are weird people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
aaron is with us in kansas city hi erin
how are you
good how are you doing dave better than
i deserve what's up
good
hey i got a question um
so i have a daughter that's getting
ready to start college next year and a
son that's going to be a sophomore in
high school
um
i just want your advice um we don't have
debt except for our house
but
you know
we've been blessed last couple years our
pay has increased you know quite a bit
more than like two years ago
but we weren't disciplined enough to
really save much for college
um
i don't want my kids going into debt
right and
my question is you know since we've had
you know a bump in our income
should i attack their college
tuition
like it's debt you know what i mean like
she's getting ready to enroll next year
where i don't have to take out any loan
or anything like that because i don't
want to do that or
what what's your
what is your household income
um we're right around
200 okay all right
um
[Music]
yes you can cash flow this college um it
is based on a couple of things
um and you're gonna have to do it with a
plan
unlike unlike how you got here right
so um one of the things we know for sure
the biggest element on being able to
cash flow college is college choice
right that debt free college is college
choice when you choose a college when
you choose a bentley
on car lot and you have a chevrolet
budget
you're about to go in debt
right and so you you are not on the
bentley lot my man you're broke
you're broke with a good income
so this young lady is going to a
wonderful state university with in-state
tuition
yeah maybe even yeah and maybe even a
community college for the first two
years to get her
uh some of the basics out of the way or
maybe even both right she can do yeah
she
she will have about a year
going into it and we are going to state
school so um go live at home
um actually she'll be about two hours
away um so
going to kansas going to kansas soon
yeah yes sir okay all right yeah yeah
well i got a jayhawk in my family so
that's all right
well it's a wildcat oh oh oh you're
going that way okay kansas city yeah
yeah
um but yeah we don't you know like i
said we don't have any debt um now it's
just
i was trying to look at this is like
gazelle intensity well how much is how
much is kansas day a year have you
looked it up
yeah um you know she'll get some
scholarship so
with everything around twenty two
thousand um no no it's not twenty two
thousand tuition
no room and borders you're talking
you're talking about important yeah i
was asking i'm asking tuition how much
is the tuition oh yeah 9 500. okay all
right that sounds right and uh and so 22
000 if you if that all goes in that's 2
000 a month out of a 200 000 income 24
000 a year
yes sir and you cash flow that out of a
thing and that does not even require
gazelle intensity that just requires a
budget item you just have 2000 a month
for college
yeah in your budget
and i would i want to warn you two
things one is
be very diligent about the actual costs
not well yeah you know and you'll get
that fafsa sheet that says here's what
our estimated cost and
watch every dollar just like you do in
your home budget because it can balloon
on you and set up have hard
conversations with your daughter about
she has to work for spending money or
she has to work for laundry money or
whatever those things are have very firm
conversations and remember this
the entire there's an entire industry
based on parent guilt when it comes to
college choice
yeah and it's like dave said except they
get a bunch of cool attractive young
people who will take young people to the
bentley lot
and then talk about and drive them
around and give them a great experience
and then they'll send the kid back to
mom and dad and say mom if you loved me
you'd give me this car right and you
guys screwed up and didn't handle your
business right
this is the car i should be driving this
is what everyone's gonna drive to get to
where we're gonna go i need you to know
that that you're you're
you're being preyed upon don't fall
victim to that ksu is a great college
your kid can do great things from that
school but go in with a firm plan don't
buy into any of that guilt nonsense okay
so we're watching stuff like the
cafeteria plan
yeah what's it cost what's it entail and
oh by the way if we're gonna get the one
where you eat there all the time you're
gonna eat there all the time kiddo and
have a hard conversation i had this with
a buddy of mine recently who's a
physician whose kid was about you know
almost gonna lose a scholarship
have the conversation now if you lose
your scholarships
you will come home you will go to
community college have all that now so
it's not drama later on down the road so
a everybody's clear right
and that lack of clarity is what got you
here in the first place so let's do
something different this time real
detailed plan we'll send you a copy of
the book um that free degree that'll
show you how to walk through it and i
recommend you sit down with your uh with
your teen and your spouse and watch
borrowed future tonight yes
it's the documentary that we did on
student loan debt and how epic out of
control stupid it is
and uh it's several hundred thousand
people have viewed it you can watch it
on google play or apple tv
or on amazon prime easy enough you can
just run it for the nice like three
bucks whatever the documentaries are
right now 399 whatever it is and so you
can watch it uh john's is featured in it
as one of the people and uh it'll just
it'll scare the bejesus out of you about
student loan debt and cause you to
really focus on this plan and so yes you
can cash flow this but it's all about
choices yeah it's all about choices and
it's all about choosing to be a grown-up
we are not paying for a degree in beer
pong
you are going there to study
pass your dadgum classes
show up to class there's an amazing
correlation between people who show up
to class and those are pass yeah it's
really strong amazing correlations you
follow the syllabus that graduate in
four years because you it's all it's all
laid out yeah and and the classes are
all available for you to graduate in
four years they're all right there
nobody tricks you
you just have to go check box check box
check box check box you are managing a
project and this project is four years
long and this is what we're gonna do and
uh well i'm not i'm not that doesn't
sound very fun this ain't about fun
darling that's about getting your
education yep you can if you want if you
want fun join a country club go the fair
um this is not it's not about fun go go
to the fair cause it's suddenly 1808
right
hey kids go to universal i don't care
but um
hey kids go to the fair let's go
let's play let's let's take the cow they
do have funnel cakes and
the uh
goldfish toss 1808
1808
you have been to the fair and you were
not even thought of you know what all
right then shut up what's up earl
haggard at the fair i love it leave me
alone funnel cakes i saw merle i did i
saw marl haggard at the home depot but
that doesn't mean
[Laughter]
all right so that's the thing it's all
about choice john has a phd in higher ed
so he actually knows how to answer these
questions
and that's one of the reasons he was
interviewed he was actually interviewed
before his ramsey personality yeah for
that documentary and
uh that documentary is blown up it is
causing a holy ruckus there are some
people in higher ed
not happy with ramsey
because we kind of told the truth about
what a screw job some of this is and
certainly the people that sally may and
navian don't like us because we expose
their misbehavior we also call congress
a bunch of fools but we've been doing
that for 20 years so that ain't nothing
new okay i think it's good to point out
like this father here yeah
you will pay for it at some point you'll
pay for it by when they're young and
you're putting money away for college
or
you're going to not be able to pay your
house off in baby step six because
you're going to cash flow college if
that's what you choose to do but again
it's going to cost you at one end of
this spectrum or the other so if you can
plan for it ahead of time
it's kind of like christmas you know
people every year people are surprised
oh gosh
they're right your kid's going to turn
18. have a plan and start having that
conversation it's going to happen yeah
and and you know we had the conversation
about a lot of things like where you're
going to go to school
and uh well you just want to discuss
because you went there no it's not
because i went there i mean you can go
to another in-state school to pay for
that one yeah but i mean any of them
that are in state i'll pay for it yeah
but um but you know in-state tuition but
you know one of them thought they were
going to go across the county line down
here into another state it was 14 000
more a year i'm like who's paying for
that
they're like well oh oh oh no so what's
no difference is just they're both the
school yeah you're going the one up here
is cheaper this is not a hard
conversation here
gee this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john delonie co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today as we talk about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five your mental health
your relationships your job your career
your money it's all a possible subject
so back in the fall
we aired for the first time the premier
airing
of the first full-length major
documentary that ramsey networks has
done it's called borrowed future
and a borrowed future is all about the
incredible rip-off how student loans are
killing the american dream
the incredible rip-off the epic failure
of the student loan program
in that uh
documentary we interviewed
all kinds of experts from seth godin to
seth fratman dr john deloney was
interviewed before he was a ramsey
personality
mike rowe of dirty jobs interviewed of
course i'm interviewed
and and we had uh several different
people who were saddled with different
levels of student loan debt uh that were
featured then we showed there's personal
stories as a part
of the program amari simmons was one of
the ladies one of the people that was
featured on the documentary and she at
that time was still a student at the
university of tennessee and had piled up
some student loan debt and uh she came
by to visit today to tour the studios
and to tour the building and see
everything she had never been here we
had gone down to knoxville our crew had
to film with her and to meet her down
there and so we all felt like we all
knew her because we watched her on the
big screen so many times in the edit
room and then later in the finally in
the premiere and everything else so it's
uh it's good to get to hang out with her
today she came by and i said well if
you're coming by we're going to sit and
talk for a minute and talk about
borrowed future with dr john baloney
welcome amari hi thank you it is so good
to have you
thanks for visiting us yeah of course
so tell us uh tell the folks out there
that maybe have not seen borrowed future
yet
about the the student loan debt that you
got into and how that occurred
uh so you want to give like number
amount i don't care whatever you want
whatever you want to do
um so i had about 13 000 in student loan
debt and that was including scholarships
um
for my four years so that just happened
because my family i'm from a single
parent home
so
simply she just couldn't afford to put
me through
through college on her own salary so
um
pushed for scholarships and i did get a
full ride scholarship to university of
tennessee but about
after like a year into my sophomore year
i had lost a scholarship
because of grades
i didn't really know how to study so i
wasn't really prepared for the rigor of
college
and university of tennessee is pretty
rigorous even though it's a public
university it's not the easiest but
i just wasn't set up in a way where i
knew how to balance
life as an adult and then now college
and grades and my major at the time i
was a biology major switched it
the word for that
um so at the time it just it was
difficult for me it was adjusting while
also trying to live up to the
expectation that i have to get through
school i have to get a degree i have to
make money you know i have to live this
life that
adults tell you you should be living you
know so where did you hear this idea
that you had to go to college
if you want to be successful
just been told that all your life yeah
in school it's kind of like that's what
the focus was you know you're getting
good grades so you can go to college so
you can get into college you know the
focus was a.c.t you're always having to
do act prep take the a-c-t take the
a-c-t take the a-c-t what does the
a-t-c-t use for to get into college
you know so that's that was the focus
and you're spending
your whole life as a kid in school
you brought you brought up something so
important
you said i got there and i had this big
fancy scholarship i didn't understand as
an 18 year old
the weight of that scholarship and what
that all meant and suddenly i'm thrown
into
class with some classes a couple hundred
people are in these classes
and i didn't have the study skills i did
when i back up and i think
we're just writing blank checks to 18
year olds and say make good choices
right
millions and millions and millions of us
didn't get great coaching with how to do
that right
what do you
walk us through i'm 18 i'm kind of
having unlimited everything
and i i'm not prepared for unlimited
everything
uh i mean it just feels like well in
high school
grades getting good grades it was easy
for me right but also
the the challenge of my high school
coursework was not challenging so
it was easy for me to get a's
you know i consider myself smart
but we didn't really have to dig deeper
into understanding what it is that
you're actually learning and then
applying it
to other things which is the bulk of
college it's college right yeah you're
not just memorizing something and now
you have to write it down on a test
you're having to apply what you what you
learn and so it's a whole different
skill set yeah and so in high school i
personally just don't feel like i was
prepared for that and then going to a
university like tennessee it's huge yeah
you know it's huge you get lost you have
a lot of distractions if you don't know
how to
label distraction from something that's
a resource
you know so you get involved because
that's the next thing you wanna you get
involved you wanna you wanna form a
community you wanna be a part of
something you wanna have belonging so
you join all these different things and
i realized oh i still have to study for
class i have a test on friday but now i
have all these other responsibilities
that come along with
being in organizations now you uh you've
graduated now
and the debt has paid off yes way to go
congratulations so proud for you proud
of you well done and you've got the
degree in what
china family studies child and family
yeah good good and so you're out here
you've been out of school now how long
for like two
two years yeah yeah
sneaks up on us
it was like three years ago we were
shooting some of that footage yeah i
think you were a senior when we were
down there shooting that no not yet i
was like a junior okay all right way
back there okay cool
very cool so now that you're out and the
student loan is behind you um one of the
things you said real quickly was in in
the documentary you said it's not fair
or it's not right that is so normalized
it's like everybody has one and it's i
think the phrase was something like you
know if you meet a perfect stranger we
can talk about student loans something's
wrong if we all have that in common yeah
yeah that's true yeah the normalization
of that i mean so you didn't think
anything about taking out the loan at
the time just because everybody did it
no not really i mean i did
but it was one of those things where
it's like okay you kind of don't have a
choice so it doesn't really matter
that intuitively you're against it you
know it's like this is what you need to
do if you want to meet the goal that you
set for yourself which is to break
change and set a different path for not
only you but your future family and your
present family you know very cool amari
simmons we're honored to have you with
us proud of you
incredible permanent member of the
ramsey family you come by anytime and
hang out
the documentary is borrowed future it's
available to watch right now on apple tv
amazon prime video google play or you
can go to borrowed future dot com and
watch it hundreds of thousands already
have no teenager should be walking
around without having seen this it is
the antidote for anyone wanting a
student loan you'll never want one if
you see this documentary thanks for
dropping by amari you're welcome this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me 130 000 all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money is new book own your
past change your future is on pre-sale
at ramseysolutions.com
you really ought to get it for 20
because you get a couple hundred dollars
worth of items thrown in when you do
that you really don't want to miss out
on this uh mike is with us in st louis
hey mike how are you
i'm good dave how you doing better than
i deserve what's up
well i'm just going to give you a
rundown of
my
my wife and i situation
both 35 years old we make about 125 000
a year combined
we both have great jobs a very stable
income
we no other debt thanks to you
debt free we have about
80 000 in cash right now in liquid cash
and bank
um
two kids one on the way coming in july
yay
yeah so uh
but we since the start of the pandemic
um
actually right before everything shut
down
we bought and sold and then we bought
and sold two more times
since then
how come why'd you do that
well we didn't plan on doing it we just
uh the house that we
first went to after we
sold
we just it was one of those cookie
cutter neighborhoods
next door neighboring of having a pit
bull in the backyard and we didn't want
our kids around that
and we just kind of saw what the prices
were doing so
we sold it i bought another one through
a friend or an
acquaintance so the buy owner home
but that one was also in another
neighborhood we just weren't
real satisfied with we bought it just
because it was kind of it was cheap
um so then we sold and then bought one
more time
now where we're at
but we each time obviously we've
gone up and home and uh so the homework
now costs uh four hundred thousand
uh we put ten thousand down how on is
your house
house payment is around it's about 2100.
okay
what's your question um
well i guess my question is like do we
have too much house
i feel comfortable with it
i know it's not within your
guidelines right now with where we're at
but i feel like we can grow actually it
should be
i mean we tell people not to have a
house payment more than a fourth of
their take-home pay
and your take-home pay not i mean not
counting retirement coming out or health
insurance coming out but take home pay
after taxes and your take-home pay ought
to be
nine grand anyway
it's about seven seventy five hundred
because uh i'm a teacher so i get
i get a lot taken out for my attention
but that's not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about your take-home pay
after taxes not
after take-home pay with your pension
or take home pay for 401k or take home
pay for your health insurance that's not
we don't count that i'm talking about
your gross minus your taxes
shouldn't be more than a fourth of that
now did you put this on a 15 year fixed
we did not it's on a 30 which i know
it's not the best but no it's all 30 on
on three percent yeah and you need to
get so you need to work to get it paid
off as soon as you can but no you're not
you're not in over your head on house
i'll tell you what you are doing
impulsing houses
is straight up stupid
these three moves
very expensive
very expensive i mean and so
if you're gonna buy a house
we find out what's in the backyard of
the next door neighbor before we buy
the house if you're gonna buy a house
you you there's a permanence
to that that you have to consider all
the possible variables you can't just go
out for the weekend and come home with a
new house yeah i'd be willing to bet
there's some anxiety issues there's some
marriage there's something going on
there's some running happening just
ping-ponging back and forth and being in
house number three and already thinking
well maybe i should uh let's
somebody is also not gonna make you
happy no it will not
in fact
make you sad and so what you need to do
is you need to sit your butt in that
house and not move again
for a long time and then when you feel
uncomfortable you feel that itch you
feel the things starting to rattle deal
with that don't figure out what's
causing the rattle
not the thing yes so
yeah you're you're you're jumping around
man i mean you impulsing houses
that'll get you and
especially in this kind of market dave
i've i've had this in the new book i've
been there like you've impulsed houses
i've impulsed yeah man and it and it was
covering up
an internal thing that i was just the
machine was saying run run run run run
oh and you were sure you're running i'm
running from this rental house to that
rental house to this bought this house
sold this house moved me and my wife to
a residence hall on a college campus
trying to just try just frantic to do a
thing without getting to the court
issues so i've been down that road
before yeah somebody that's running
megan's in topeka kansas hey megan
welcome to the ramsay show hey dani hey
john how you guys doing good what's up
um
i need to talk to you guys about a
stress that has been bothering me for
about five years um i adopted my
daughters back in 2017 my oldest
daughter and
um
her biological mom kept her
first social security card
and we got her social security number
changed
and we got her last name changed but
when we went to the social security
office they told us that there was no
guarantees
that her biological mother couldn't take
out a credit card or open up a loan on
that social security number
and
um
the lawyer that we had he did everything
he could to try and get it from her she
just wasn't surrendered i mean you can't
guarantee the bank isn't going to get
robbed by a crook
and the mother the mother the birth
mother's obviously
you know got major issues going on she's
crook potentially that's what's scaring
you holds a kid right now
she's um gonna be ate next month good
well awesome that's great have you read
a credit report on her
i don't i well that was one of my
questions is i didn't know if i was
legally allowed to sure you're her
parent yeah you're a guardian absolutely
okay the other thing you can do that you
need to do is you need to freeze her
credit yeah freeze the other credit yeah
yeah i just need to know all the ways i
can protect her
well number one you can't yeah
completely
because there's skunks in the world and
it's the potential that her
birth mother's a skunk we don't know for
sure but there's a potential that's what
you're calling but the things you can do
is you can check the check it make sure
there's nothing on it uh the second
thing you can do is freeze it
okay now if you freeze it what happens
is if someone checks her credit in order
to issue a
debt like a credit card for instance in
her name if they check her credit and
it's frozen they will not issue the debt
so birth mother uses uh old social
security number new social security
number new name old name whatever and
they check her credit and it's frozen
then
the credit card will be denied here's
the problem
only 3 in 10 credit cards do they
actually run a credit check on they just
automatically issue 7 of them that's how
dead people and dogs get cards
you can get a dog issue in your poodle's
name
and i mean a card these those should
cause these credit card companies are
stupid
they're just they're because in mass it
works out for them and they're just
running scale they're running large
numbers and so they might still
issue a card to the kid so what i would
do is i would go to zander insurance and
i would buy identity theft on the family
plan
and that includes coverage for your kids
it's not that expensive identity theft
insurance protection and what it'll do
then is if if someone
birth mother included uh stole her
identity and illegally opened a card in
her name
then they would assign a counselor to
that case
and get it all removed and cleaned up
for you
and that's why i carry it on me my
family
can i buy that
even
if she has coverage through my husband's
work
because i've been wanting to
she has coverage for what
through xander insurance
well through lifelock well lifelock does
not assign a counselor
they do not assign someone to take care
of it for you yes i'd pay the money yes
i would pay
because lifelock is just a monitoring
service
and take a breath you did something
noble and good
and it sounds like you're pre worrying
about things that might happen down the
road yeah
be present here be with your kid here
things are good things are good
enjoy the ride yeah man parenting's hard
enough as it is without imagining things
that could happen
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us america as we
talk about your relationships your
careers and your money every day here on
the ramsay show in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage dean
and beth are with us hey guys how are
you wonderful dave good to have you guys
where do you live
simi valley california that's a bit of a
haul to nashville just a bit welcome all
the way over here on the other side of
the world to do a debt-free screen how
much have you paid off uh we paid off
just over 408 thousand dollars
which includes the house whoa yeah
look at the weird people
and uh while we did that we cashflowed
uh both of our sons through college that
was just about
83 000. wow
that's impressive pretty cool and how
long did this take you
almost 12 years all right very good and
your range of income over that decade
plus
well it started about 105
but i didn't work for a whole lot of
that time and now i am working so right
now we're i don't know what we're right
now
just under 200 000. okay all right good
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a program manager for the department
of navy
and i'm a staff accountant at johnny and
friends oh wow
johnny's a friend yeah and johnny and
friends are friends yeah and ken too how
are they doing they're doing very well i
actually just saw them last friday oh
cool we'll give her a hug for us we love
her
and him as well so hey good to have you
guys so what started you on this journey
12 years ago
i'm gonna try not to cry
um so christmas 2008
i had bought him a computer part that he
wanted that i didn't understand at all
and it apparently ended up being the
wrong part so when he went to call to
get a exchange the credit card got
denied
and so he went it's like i knew he had a
lot of credit card debt but i never told
it up totaled it up but he um got into
the filing cabinet pulled out all the
bills to hold it up and went
we have to figure out what we're doing
and
so i thought we were getting a divorce
and then our church offered fpu
and
about what week seven he looked at me
and he said so when we retire and it was
the first time i went okay this is an us
thing
but i mean we've done all of the
budgeting and everything like that and
had the conversations but it was when he
said that when we retire i was like okay
we're good we'll make it we're going to
learn
so you were handling the whole thing by
yourself yes she was dave yeah yep
and
carrying all of that and it wasn't
working and you knew it wasn't working
but you never said anything
i didn't know how to yeah i don't blame
you i understand that was a hundred and
ten thousand dollars of unsecured debt
yeah mostly credit cards uh credit cards
and two car loans okay yeah all right
yeah we dug ourselves a really deep hole
okay and you're just going off making
money coming home making money coming
home and never even thought about it
yeah
yeah i thought with an engineering
degree and she had a finance degree we
got to be doing all right and uh turns
out we were far from it yeah
yeah so when you get that filing cabinet
out
were you afraid or angry or both
uh i really didn't know what to expect
that's how unplugged i was with i mean
when you got it all out and figured out
what was going on i was terrified i had
no idea what to do
yep
and so uh as as beth said our church was
offering fpu i wasn't i kept hearing the
commercials every sunday and and uh
just thought well that's not for us
that's not for us and so when i saw this
i said well
i think it was about a hundred dollars
at the time yep what's another hundred
dollars when you're 110 000 in debt so
we figured we'd give it a shot
it still by the way is a hundred dollars
inflation you know hasn't affected mpu
right
everything else is doubled and think
about how much your house went up and
gas went up fpu still the same price 12
years ago yes i love uh also most would
call those church announcements but i
love how you said i was listening to the
commercials
yes
yes
what church
stonebridge community church yeah okay
cool
wow you guys so you went you went week
one we went week one how did that feel
uh uh awkward right we didn't know what
to expect it never heard anything about
you or financial peace university that's
hillbilly running up down the stage yeah
yes sir well and i've been doing budgets
for years just never a zero balance
budget even working for a church we
never did a zero balance budget right
and so it was like well it can't hurt
well until we had our first budget i
mean
yeah so how'd that go it hurt a little
yeah that was a long that was a long
afternoon that was a very long afternoon
yeah
that's the most military statement
sharon man we had a knock down drag out
that day that was a long day our first
one whoo
neither one of us were nice but a
hillbilly says it was a knock down drag
out and a military man says it was a
long afternoon it was a very long
afternoon
yep and so i did what i usually do and
started making a spreadsheet and it's
ridiculously uh sophisticated today but
um it's got retirement tabs and it's got
the boys college tab when they were in
school and it's got
annual tab and a monthly tab and yeah
macros and buttons and
then when it doesn't work she just calls
me and
i walk her through some fix
so we live in a culture that most people
quit their new year's resolutions within
45 days of the new year yes sir you guys
have been doing this over a decade yeah
what kept y'all going uh well uh it was
difficult um
facilitating classes actually yeah yes
every year we would teach we would help
facilitate a class and it was like
taking it again and we'd we'd always
hear something new so it was like i
think we were talking about it and it
wasn't until like the third one where we
really listened to the insurance company
one lesson and finally called the
insurance company and said hey
let's have a discussion
awesome
yeah we we struggled with uh so much
debt we knew that that wasn't going to
be measured in months and so um
i need to have little victories just so
i can stay motivated so by facilitating
classes that was a big help uh and then
just we would set up little mini
milestones i mean the the uh the baby
steps helped but when you got 110 000
you're on that baby step for a very long
time yeah
and so we would just set little
milestones of you know we'd get the debt
down to 50 000 and we would go do a
humble dinner but just go out to
celebrate and yeah so we had all these
little milestones that were just barely
out of reach but enough that kept us
motivated and kept us challenged
yes sir all the way through yes sir
sounds like it impacted your marriage
too
uh hugely so um
uh we were married for
what uh we got married in 90 we did this
in 2009 so it's that 19 years
and we would have the financial
arguments um
with money uh until
february 2009 and dave i can tell you
that we have never argued once about
money since then once you got past that
first budget commitment right
we would be we would be frustrated with
the numbers but but our our frustration
was focused on that spreadsheet was
focused on the zero balance budget uh
never with each other so it was uh
figuring out how to how to do what we
wanted to do with the money we had
knowing that it has to sum to zero at
the bottom of the page
so beth i'm looking at you okay you're
still carrying this as though this
happened yesterday right some parts of
it yes and so here's the thing
your story
nothing is wasted
the journey you and your husband have on
will inspire millions who are in your
exact same exact same situation listen
to this driving down the road and your
bravery over the last decade will heal
marriages you're not going to only
change your family tree you're going to
change other family trees and so when we
leave nashville today this story this
pain that you're carrying with you set
that down here and it stays here fair
fair all right i'm proud of you you're
such a gift it's so cool it's already
changed the next generation our sons we
talk one of the years we taught
foundations also at the church
and both of them are debt free and out
of college
during the pandemic finish school and
ended up getting to get full-time jobs
and moved out my older son actually came
to me as he was looking at apartment at
apartments with his laptop and said okay
here's my budget what do you think and i
was like
[Laughter]
this is how you make some moms cry
he's responsible he's not gonna live in
the basement yeah this is great well
done y'all you guys are amazing i'm so
proud of you well done we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story you're on
your way if you're not already there how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too count it down
let's hear a debt free screen 408 000
paid off in 12 years
ready three two one we're
[Applause]
yeah baby
boom
just like that
this is the ramsey chef
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us
as we're talking with the last couple on
the debt free scream during the
commercial break they shared with us
which i should have asked them when they
were on the air i goofed
um but they're with their retirement
plans and with the paid for house their
net worth is 1.67
so they go from
12 years ago opening the filing cabinet
she's afraid he's going to divorce her
when she discuss when he discovers how
bad a mess they've made
he takes ownership of the fact he had
not helped
she takes ownership of the fact she
shame-based and didn't bring all the
mess forward
and together they go into the financial
peace university class they keep
facilitating the class throughout the
years
they get everything paid off 110 000
worth of consumer debt plus a paid plus
a house in simi valley california and a
couple of kids through college and a
couple kids through college who are all
responsible and doing their own budget
with their computer
and showing it to mom and all that 408
000 paid off in 12 years but
in the midst of that they followed the
baby steps exactly so they are truly
baby steps millionaires yeah
that's quite a turnaround i mean this
goes from a negative net worth
to 1.67 in 12 years and i've never heard
of all the debt-free screams i've been a
part of i've never heard somebody
because a hundred thousand dollars in
unsecured debt staggering that's a huge
credit card bill right those credit card
cars right yeah
but
the psychology is right you got to have
little wins to make progress in anything
right that's depression 101 that's
anxiety you could have little wins that
snowball yeah right but
you know what they did they did they
served
so they led classes for the little wins
and so that meant that other people were
getting their little credit card here
paid off and they were registering that
is we're contributing and we often get
stuck staring in our own mirrors at our
own belly buttons wondering about me
poor me poor me service is one of the
great things you can do to get out of
yourself and get those little wins with
being around other people that are
winning keeps you moving forward well
get out of yourself is the trick yeah
because what a great idea we are we're
taught by
so many things in this toxic culture to
gaze inward just think about it over and
over just gaze inward
naval gazing to the point that that um
you can think your way through something
um and sometimes you just need to get up
off your butt and go go do go help
somebody oh do yeah don't go mow
somebody's grass i mean go clean up go
clean out their gutters
go go teach a financial peace university
class while you're broke what yes you
know and and while you're working it and
so you you know you're relatable to the
people that are in there when you're the
coordinator because you know you're not
above them somehow
uh so many things are taught by people
who are above it right and uh that's
really one of the big things about the
whole ramsey brand is we're not above
anything we're right there with you
that's exactly maybe maybe we're maybe
we're uh mathematically above where you
are uh but we have been right where you
are and
uh you get there so that that's a big
deal but those quick win those quick
wins with small wins that that loop is a
big deal that's service yeah good for
you guys yeah i'm taking
um those who are uh first will be last
those are last will be first cody's with
us and charlotte hey cody welcome to the
ramsey show
hey can you hear me dave absolutely
what's up
hey man thanks for taking my call
um so i have have a
bit of a situation i was wanting your
opinion on
i'm a real estate agent i have been for
about a year now
and i
wasn't making i i made okay money last
year but we just found out we have a
baby coming in september so i was
wanting to try to save up a little bit
of money for the baby and i took a
part-time job at lowe's i just got
accepted for that and i was wanting your
opinion about if i should
continue doing real estate part time and
try to stack some cash doing that even
though it's really
you know commission based there's a
chance i might not make a lot of money
or if i should go full time
with a nine to five and try to stack
money that way
you do not have a full-time job now
no sir i just started part-time because
when did you when did you start the real
estate business one year ago
yes sir how much have you made
last year i made 33.
thousand dollars
yes sir
okay
um
how many houses do you have listed right
now
oh well i have three houses in one lot
one vacant lot
okay
when did you make what did you make the
second six months not the first six
months
well my first six months was better than
my second because my mom is a broker in
charge so i kind of tagged along on some
of her
transactions which i realized i made 16
off of her alone
from helping her out so that's what kind
of got me nervous about this coming up
year sorry i think six months
i'm 30. okay
well it's a hot time to sell real estate
why are you not selling real estate
um i don't know i've been doing cold
calls i've been trying to do a lot of
prospecting um
so i'm not exactly sure if it's you know
what's going on as far as why it's not
doing better but i mean it is my my
first year so i was didn't know if it
was just that or what
well there are people that
flame out in the first year and they're
the people that succeed
amazingly in the first year and those
are lots of people in the middle in the
first year that's not unusual
but basically you made fourteen thousand
dollars in the real estate business in
one year you haven't made any money
and
my realtor that walked us through our
situation which was just a regular old
house purchase and with a pain in the
butt client it was me
i tell everybody about her i want
everyone to know about amanda cause she
was incredible with my family with my
kids
there's a gap between i i'm concerned
that you don't know that you can't put
your finger on it um if you ask me how i
can get better at my job that i'm in
right now that i'm still learning i'm
still a baby at this i i know because
the guys tell me and we keep track of
that stuff
i'm concerned that you're just like well
i don't know i'm just making some call
you've got to have a couple of concrete
things have you sat down with your mom
and asked her what am i not doing
yeah yeah and i think the biggest um
issue i was have i was having was
prospecting and that's how i got the
leads that i have now i started my
prospecting up a lot stronger in january
of or actually in december of last year
so
throughout the past two months i got all
the listings i have now through
prospecting oh that's good i kind of
buckled down on the whole so we got we
at least have a good trend line now
okay so you got you got the because
listings are money in the bank in your
world
if you if you've listed the property
properly at a proper price in this
market
it's getting ready to turn into money
it's gonna sell yeah sure it's gonna
sell so all the listings you can get are
just that's money in the bank that's
just making a deposit you just can't
make the withdrawal quite yet so uh but
if your prospecting is if you've gotten
more business on the books in the last
60 days than you did the entire year
before that then then we're on to
something aren't we
yes sir okay
so uh sounds like you need to double
your prospecting one more time
okay i want you to become a prospecting
machine
and uh you can make a lot more doing
this and you can work in part time at
lowe's
dave let me ask you this
how many people get into the real estate
business
and look at
they
flip over a napkin and they do the math
if i sell this many houses i'll make
this much money
and underestimate the work it takes to
sell a house all of them okay okay
everybody it's like any business you go
into you think it's going to take twice
as long as you think it's going to it's
going to cost twice as much as you think
it's going to and you're not the
exception these are the three rules of
business
and it goes over and over and over again
you know i've never heard those but the
uh
you know and the the rule in the real
estate business the problem the real
estate business is you're self-employed
right
and there's nobody leaning over you
going you made your 300 calls this week
um i was with one of our marketing teams
this morning looking at some stuff and
they said these guys are doing 300 calls
i'm going that's how you do it yeah it's
there's there's no exception for
activity when listen man so what you've
got to remember
uh cody in your situation is if you're
not kneecap to kneecap eyeball to
eyeball
or digitally through email or telephone
talking to someone about buying or
selling a piece of real estate
if you're not doing that any moment
you're not doing that you are unemployed
i like that you're not in the real
estate business you're just unemployed
you're just an unemployed guy
and i in the real estate business i call
them donut eaters because they would sit
around the office eat donuts and whine
about the economy and the president
instead of getting up off their butt
leaving the cave killing something and
dragging it home but it's all about
activity it's all about uh prospecting
in in your case cody so yeah turn that
up and if that doesn't work in 90 days
you may need to go do something else
but i think it's going to i think you
figured out what was going on i think
you haven't been disciplined about your
marketing
and if you turn that up to a high
octane level you should be fine get it
cody get it
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk about your relationships your
mental health your boundaries your
career your work and your money it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five
five
anthony's with us in phoenix hi anthony
how are you
good dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i was calling today to get some
advice on whether or not i should sell
my truck to get out of debt faster
so to tell you a little bit about the
truck it's uh you might dave i think
personally understand the feelings that
i have about this is a ford raptor
um however however i would like to know
if i should sell the truck to get out of
that faster or if i should pay it off
which by my
calculations i should be able to do
within the next year what do you owe on
it
i owe 55. and what's your household
income
household income is uh 150 a year okay
what's the other car are you married
i'm not okay single guy the only vehicle
guy making 150 the only vehicle you own
and it's apparently it's one of the few
deaths you have
right okay our rule of thumb is if you
have a vehicle that's in question
if it is that all of your vehicles added
together anything with car with wheels
and motors or motors
added together should be less than half
your annual income and you should be
able to be debt-free not counting your
house within two years of the time you
start your debt snowball if it's going
to take longer than that and it's the
car's fault or if the car is more than
cars or boats or sea doos or their
sisters are more than half the annual
income then we start pairing off the
junk that has motors and wheels and so
forth so your car is less than half your
annual income you can be debt-free in
under two years there's no reason to
sell it
okay that does not mean i would go into
debt to buy it originally but now that
you find yourself there get it paid off
or anthony i've got a deal for you i
have an o6 tundra i'll trade you
straight up
that's just because i love him
that's why he's hard he's here he's here
to help you anthony
yeah but he got up this morning and said
i'm here for the people
and the fans of the show
and i really john that's big hearted of
you i appreciate you noticing that um i
have a huge heart uh people have gotten
themselves in hard situations you have
uh you have uh
missed the sarcasm font
on that email brother
way to go anthony yeah keep the truck
baby keep the truck danny's in syracuse
hi danny welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave uh i've enjoyed your practical
advice over the past few years and i
would like a little bit of your insight
into comprising a wheel okay um
specifically
uh
will basically has uh several
beneficiaries most of them or all of
them rather are financially responsible
except for one
uh very irresponsible the only thing
they've learned is to use a credit card
and have dad come in and pay it
that's a recipe for collecting the
inheritance and starting the fast clock
from seven hundred thousand to broke
so
i've heard you suggested on your show
about financial peace or diversity is a
requirement
uh how can that be done
and specifically
with the entire course is there like a
practical way on having it be an ongoing
participation making that a requirement
well yeah you can just take them out of
the will until they behave
yeah you sound like you have to put it
leave them in there why do you have to
leave them in there you don't
no i i don't yeah okay let's start with
this let's start with this
there you go yeah
here's the thing an inheritance is not
an entitlement you are not entitled to
an inheritance
you are not obligated morally ethically
biblically to leave your money to anyone
in particular
now in our house we're people of faith
and to
mismanage
your life
meaning
the steward the management of your life
including your money um is you know
you're supposed to be managing your life
for god you're managing your life as as
christians we're going to manage god's
money and if you can't manage god's
money i'm i'm
duty-bound to not to give it to you to
mismanage from my perspective as a
steward number one but number two it's
not going to be a blessing to this
person it's they're gonna it's gonna
bring them harm because when you get
money it
magnifies the good and the bad in your
life so it's not about financial peace
university and it's not about being a
control freak it's about putting your
arm around this this child and saying
um
gosh
i don't want to hurt you
i love you too much to hurt you and so
i'll walk with you as you learn these
skills that you've yet to learn but
until you learn them i'm not going to be
able to leave you anything you're you're
opting out you're choosing
by your misbehavior to not be in the
will
which i agree with it's unfortunate it's
not my child
um i guess the heart strings are pulling
a little bit because
he's
has some severe health issues and will
need
some good insurance
and once his parents
are not going to get he's like
this is a nephew
my nephew
his parents are just as irresponsible as
him financially how old is he
22. okay have you taken him out and
y'all two just talked for a while
oh
tried let me put it that way okay
what did that what did that sound like
what does that sound like
well when you've got the parents on the
other i mean they'll agree with
everything you say but when you've got
the parents on the other end just uh
you know handing handing cash like it
grows on trees
that's uh it's a hard hard battle to win
who's convinced you that this is your
problem to solve
why have you taken this on
you've inserted yourself
you've inserted yourself into their
family do you feel guilty that you've
been you've made a lot of money
no not at all okay
something about the situation you've
inserted yourself into your brother or
your sister's family and taken it upon
yourself that it's your responsibility
to save their errant child
i want to free you from that man yeah
it's not your it's not on your list of
things to do
uh you know what i would do if it was my
nephew and i wanted to leave him money
to help him because he has health
problems but i think he has bigger
problems in health problems
i think he's got character issues that
supersede his health problems and may
actually add to them i don't know what
his health problems are
but may make them worse or aggravate or
exasperate the situation or whatever it
is but i'm just gonna sit down with him
and i'm gonna go hey i'm your old ugly
rich uncle you ever heard the parable
the rich uncle i'm him i'm the guy you
know that's me and so yo everybody wants
one well you got one
and so uh if you want i i would i would
love to be a blessing in your life but i
cannot do that until you learn to behave
with money if you'll walk along this if
you let me walk along beside you i'll
kick your little butt and i will hug you
into learning how to do this life thing
and money thing right
but if you don't
not say it i'm not care about what you
say if you don't do it
then i can't leave you
money in the will
but i'd like to i'd like to be the guy
that coaches you up and takes you
through this and puts you in financial
peace university and you and i talk
about it and i see the fruit in your
life but you being in the will is
dependent on that you can opt out of
this by your behavior you can opt into
this with your behavior it'll be your
choice
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr trondalone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five the housing market is hot
hot hot
so your house could be worth a lot more
today than it was when you bought it and
that means your old insurance policy
might not give you enough coverage
anymore
and what's the point of paying for
insurance that won't cover the cost of
repair or rebuild your home
yeah you've got a stated amount on your
insurance policy it may cover a little
bit more than that
but if your house is suddenly worth 700
000 and your policy is 500 000 you is
screwed if it burns so you've got to
keep your policies updated
and you have to get them raised and so
that they can raise the prices on them
that's how they do it
some automatically raise your coverage a
little bit but most of them don't
so you need to get with one of our
endorsed local providers and shop your
insurance they will shop around among a
bazillion companies get you the best
possible deal this is why we call them
ramsey trusted they're independent
insurance brokers and they'll get you a
deal go to ramseysolutions.com home to
talk with a trusted
home insurance pro
in your area home insurance elp endorsed
local provider that's ramsey trusted
ramsey solutions dot com slash home our
question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from john in
california
john writes my wife and i are
approaching 60 and have been married for
30 years she's had a gambling problem
since we got married and it's getting
progressively worse she keeps promising
to quit but every month spends thousands
of dollars on her hobby
hobby i'm just gonna underline that one
mark mark that number yeah yeah all
right she has a job but never uses her
income toward our family expenses to add
to the mess we had a daughter that i
believe to be mine until she had a dna
test that showed we are not related so
in a nutshell our marriage is a
long-term sham
at this point i have zero interest in
finding a different wife so i see two
possible paths i'll go ahead and mark
that one
we can either divorce and split our net
worth with me possibly getting strapped
with alimony payments for the rest of my
life or i can put up with her nonsense
of slowly bleeding down our savings and
investments
from a practical point of view it may be
quote unquote cheaper to keep her
but i'd still have to deal with a mental
mess what would you do in my situation
john you're a freaking tragedy wow it's
like a country song it's like two
country songs
and you know i love how you just
completely painted yourself into the
corner and there's only two possible
scenarios out of this and both of them
you die exactly i mean it's likely i'm
getting starved to death or or have a
psychotic break
i'm going to absolutely lose my mind or
we're going to be cheaper to keep her
and i'm going to tolerate you are making
an excuse for tolerating this all these
years because you had manned up and
dealt with the problems both in the last
30 freaking years
every home is built with a door on it
john
every home
and if somebody's lying to you about the
whether you're kid they're stealing good
grief
yeah you've got to deal with this asap
and
you're going to get me all fired up dude
you need to you need to answer the
question here's the question number one
a gambling problem is an addiction not a
hobby stop painting it with this milk
toast wet toast language it's an
addiction you're married to someone who
is struggling with an addiction number
two she's never used she has a job but
she never uses income towards her family
expenses that's your fault correct
number three
we have a daughter that i believe to be
mine my nut my marriage is a long-term
sham maybe
but if it is it's because you
participated in this long-term sham okay
i want you to look in the mirror none of
this is new information correct
at this point we have zero interest in
finding a different wife that is
completely irrelevant to the point that
you are worth more than living in a home
where somebody is using you as toilet
paper stop
stop
nonsense
you don't have to be interested in
finding a different wife you can be
interested in preserving your dignity
taking care of your mental and physical
health and helping your wife not deal
with her hobby but possibly get help
because she's ill
should we continue
you can at least you can divorce i'm
never gonna tell somebody to get
divorced but this is a mess you've been
cheated on you have been someone's
liquidating your money you need to go
see an attorney and or a marriage
counselor today that's what i'm saying
here's the thing
people do stupid butt stuff absolutely
they're harmful to other people
and if it happens to you once you know
shame on her it
happens to you twice happens to you
three times happens to you four times
shame on you happens to you over 30
years since we got married shame on you
for not dealing with it right
and so uh dave rims is shaming someone
oh brother you dadgum snowflakes um but
the uh the deal is this it is your fault
that you haven't dealt with this before
now correct and so and you act like
you're somehow stuck you're not stuck no
that's the
the title of my new book own your past
change your future thanks for the
underhand pitch here john from
california you've got to own what is and
what is is you've allowed this you've
allowed yourself to participate in
somebody else's illness or their
addiction or their bad behavior whatever
you want to call it for 30 years so tell
me john on this what i read is this lady
is messed up
and he's almost as messed up as she is
yes so i have
it's hard for me to be hopeful that both
of them can come around
she has uh why would she change her life
her life is fantastic
she can do whatever she wants whatever
she wants whatever she wants with no
consequence and and he just looks at it
she lives in a rent-free home just wines
and [ __ ] someone else pays their food
and what it never does anything about it
yeah so here's the deal i mean in other
words he can come in tomorrow and with
the help of a counselor say we're going
to go to a marriage counselor and in
order for me to stay here's what has to
happen
an ultimatum yep okay no more gambling
yep and your money becomes our money and
um anymore anything that looks or smells
anything like infidelity when we're done
right i mean these are non-negotiables
he could come in tomorrow and then she
could say
um oh you're right after 30 years of
doing it this way i'm just going to stop
tomorrow um
probably not right but here's what
here's probably what is going to happen
it's not a matter of him saying well
then i guess i have to do this what he
has to do is draw boundaries and then
she gets to choose do i want to be in a
relationship with him yeah and she's
already chosen that by the way that's
for 30 years she has right that she
doesn't that's right
so john you got to these are two lazy
people
uh they're lazy in that they will not
deal with their stuff yeah i was
intellectually or they're just so
traumatized yeah whatever the reason is
they're they're not dealing with their
stuff either one of them yeah is what
i'm seeing so i mean i just it's just
old voice good old boy stuff but anyway
yeah so
that's what i you you are going to if
you asking us what to do we would say
you're going to sit down with a
therapist and uh you're going to say
these are the conditions under which i
stay or you're going to just say i'm
calling it a day click out peace out and
get an attorney and to presuppose that
you're always going to pay alimony you
probably are after 30 years but that
also is a negotiation
and she probably wants free of you and
let me say this not tongue-in-cheek
john you don't know what
going to bed
just going to sleep feels like without
medication
you don't know what it's like laughing
from your guts anymore you don't know
what it's like to be with just a group
of buddies and y'all are having a good
time
you've lost that sense of joy and what i
would tell you is you're approaching 60
you got 30 years left
you can choose from this point forward
to make those 30 years the best 30 years
of your 60 or you can choose to oh this
is this way the point is both paths are
going to be hard choose which kind of
hard you want
you want hard where you slowly drown or
you want hard where you slowly stand
back up you get to pick
yeah because it is way past time to
stand up dude stand up john
way fast time to stand up this breaks my
heart dave
how many couples
in the united states live like this you
know they're roommates
but i mean people are so funny after
they get clear their sense of humor
comes back i one guy said he said i i
got rid of fifty thousand dollars worth
of debt and i said what'd you do how did
you do that and he goes that divorced
her oh gosh
you need better
we're not recommending divorce we're not
glamorizing it but that's funny
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today dylan is with us in boston
hi dylan welcome to the ramsey show
hi what a pleasure how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
so i am looking for some advice today um
i am about 55 000 in debt um 30k is in
student loans 18 is my car loan i have a
5 000 personal loan i took out
for a lower interest rate um for my
credit cards now i'm pretty new to your
baby steps program i'm just getting up
to speed and everything um i also have a
hundred thousand of parent plus loans in
my mom's name
um that she signed for for my
undergraduate at the time and i'm
looking for a plan to attack it
uh she doesn't make that much she makes
around 30 000 a year and
i just started a new job making 120 000
a year you're single
yes
okay
all right so what you're telling me is
um you feel
for
one reason or another either by
agreement with your mom
or just by the fact that she can't deal
with it you feel obligated to pay the
parent plus loans
not legally but somehow morally or
ethically
yes have you all talked about this
um from time and time again um
i want to say every few months because
it's been
delayed
with the kovid
and i know the payments are going to
start up soon with the interest
so i'm trying to get into a conversation
with her about it on our plan for it
that's a lot of dancing around the
question have you all sat down and said
i would like to take these parent plus
loans and so when they kick back up i'm
gonna take the payment over
so i guess not seriously no okay all
right
i'll have that conversation
that's an important important
conversation so your mom is single and
makes thirty thousand dollars a year
uh my mom's married um
and so her and my dad make probably
around 120. i'm not sure the exact
number i know it's over 100.
okay why is your mom part of this
discussion and not your dad
um he didn't sign on any of the loans it
was just her it was just her and me at
the time
and no you didn't sign them their parent
plus loans
yes so your mother with or without your
father's knowledge took out a hundred
thousand dollars to send her son to
college
that's correct parents do that and
generally pay it back
i don't know why your mom is saddled
with this
they have some kind of fractured
relationship is your dad choosing to not
help her
um
yes
okay um so all right so i think we're a
little confused here so my dad is in the
pressure is my stepfather
okay
hopefully she's married too okay but
he's not helping her with her debts
she said this is your debt that you deal
with
okay
yes all right well if you're gonna take
it on it simply goes in your debt
snowball
and if you're gonna sit down with the
two of them and have a conversation that
says
um i make good money i don't want to
deal with this but i don't see how
you're going to be able to deal with
this
i see it sinking you and so i'm going to
take the responsibility for it
mathematically you cannot take the legal
responsibility for it it's not legally
ever going to be yours okay
but you can just pay it so you can start
paying the payments make it part of your
budget and then you do your debt
snowball and you list your debts
smallest to largest which means the last
debt you're going to get to are these
parent plus loans which is really what
it should be
um and uh uh
you know uh
i throw one important caveat in here
get the payment information and you pay
the loan service or directly oh yeah
yeah you're not gonna pay her you're not
giving her any money you're just taking
over the loan right you get the payment
book or or the payment password to the
website whatever it is and you're going
to make the payments you're going to set
it all up and then when you get down to
it you're going to pay extra on it and
get it done you're going to pay it last
for uh three reasons one is it is not
your debt two is it's your largest debt
once you morally take it on so it's at
the bottom of your debt snowball
three is if god forbid she should pass
away the debt is forgiven
right and you would not she would not
owe it anymore
okay now i have a follow-up question
um
now what is your confidence level in uh
student loan forgiveness zero um
zero okay
so i know we're in an income driven you
can tell politicians are lying when
their mouth is moving
i like that here's the problem dylan the
problem with the student loan
forgiveness is they haven't shut off the
spigot yet
if they continue to make student loans
it's intellectually dishonest to discuss
stock
to discuss forgiving the ones that are
already in place while they're
continuing to make them so every student
when they quit making them yeah then we
can start having a discussion that it
might be happening that they're going to
forgive them but if they but they're not
even those people up there the island of
misfit toys called congress even those
guys are not so dumb that they're going
to forgive
willy-nilly all these loans everywhere
and then turn around and keep making
them and put everybody right back in and
then fall semester rolls around and
everyone's right back in here we go
let's go again
here we go everybody get in line get up
you piggies
you know no it's not that's not that
even they are not that stupid so no you
just got 120 000
60 000 bucks going into 155
so you got three years two and a half
years of beans and rice rice and beans
and you can clear every bit of this but
you have no life during the next two and
a half to three years
no inside you you know so if you go on a
date it's going to be a frisbee at the
park
i mean it's not going to be
you got you got nothing dude you're
going to die
if you're taking this on if you're
taking this on then you got to take it
on you got to treat it like you know
good the good news is you make 120 000
as a young guy yeah you know and so you
got a good sized shovel and you can just
tear your butt into this thing and
that's what you're gonna have to do you
can knock out your debts pretty quick
and then you're gonna hit the wall
called mom's debts that's right and do
not
i don't care how bad things get don't
date a frisbee don't don't
just don't
take a frisbee to the park on your date
no you said not gonna date with a
frisbee not as a date i did not say go
on a date with a friend
the cards and letters from the show john
the cards and letters john
john
oh my gosh don't do it it's been a long
day for you with the fair the fair and
the frisbee we have other personalities
back there if you don't want to swap
them out
we got another person
switch out james says we're gonna do a
personality change at the break ready
nascar crew here we go
we're changing the engine
i'm gonna go outside and play with a
frisbee uh yeah probably a good idea
it's raining shannon's in tulsa oklahoma
what's up shannon
hey guys nice to talk to you guys today
i'm looking really forward to getting
some advice from you guys on on this
going into business question that's not
a friend or family member so
um nice to talk to you guys thank you
i'm 40 years old wife my high school
sweetheart been married 21 years we're
in a great spot in our careers we we
just if we simply continue to follow the
baby steps we are well on our way to
becoming baby step millionaires by the
time we're retirement age
so it's a great got a great corporate
job 401k match pension the whole nine
the issue is i feel somewhere down deep
that i'm called to do more in life than
said at home each day behind the
computer screen for the next 20 years
and i know i've got god-given talents
and business and people skills that are
not
being utilized to their fullest so i've
got a few business opportunities that
i'm staring at that are in front of me
but they require borrowing money to take
the risk
and i just i've kind of got a two-fold
issue in front of me of
you know number one do i risk what god's
laid out for us over these last over
these several years and and put us in
place to be successful with how much
money do you like
how much money do we have yes sure we
don't have a lot of reserve we just
finished baby step three not too long
ago and we we're we're good there are
lots lots of businesses you can start
without going into debt
okay
okay should that be maybe the direction
i look into
as a side as a side hustle
and remember god will never call you
into something that violates your core
violates well his own core principles
that's probably what's turmoiling inside
of me is is it just it seems like i have
to borrow and it just goes against you
know it even sounds not you know it
doesn't even sound right in my heart but
every businessman you talk to and
successful person they say well you
can't be successful no they don't no you
that you can't say that ever again
because you just talked to one
that doesn't believe that and i've
talked to them all the time every day
i've talked to debt free guys all over
this nation debt-free gals all of this
nation running businesses so you're
overstating that when you say every
businessman they don't now maybe you
just hadn't talked to the right ones yet
maybe you're talking to high rollers or
something risk takers but i'm going to
tell you don't borrow money to start a
business
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 14 30 a
heart at peace gives life to the body
but envy
brought the bones teddy roosevelt said
if you could kick the person in the
pants that's responsible for your
trouble you wouldn't sit for a month
well that's the truth
so john there is a ship adrift
has been abandoned that has 438
million dollars in total value of goods
it's on fire
and it's the and so the the crew
abandoned ship massive
freighter
and it's full
of volkswagen's porsches audis bentleys
and lamborghinis
and it's burning
and drifting through the ocean with no
one on it they all got off and said
peace out i've had a lot of professional
whoopsie-doos in my career dave i can
honestly say
oops
wow
wow
the guy the guy that was having a smoke
break next to one of those cars
and it just went up on him and he went
oh captain that's right captain we got
whoops
but the two guys were like hey you won't
throw that over that thing and i dare
you i dare you 100 like this is um
that's unbelievable the vehicles alone
are worth over 155 million according to
one consultant's estimate
now yeah we need to get a consultant to
estimate these um there's a dadgum
manifest there's a list of exactly
what's on there you don't really need to
estimate them you can just add up the
value
it's like you should not you should know
what's on there but anyway
what a heartbreaking mess
good grief she said they got two tugs
with firefighting equipment expected to
arrive today
monday morning which was yesterday for
most people no that's today
yeah i'm so confused start spraying
water no spray water
oh it's awful
you know and i gotta tell you guys every
there's there's a certain number of guys
that i'm trying to they're trying to
figure out how they can get could i swim
out here that's how i can get one of
those lamborghinis off of that boat okay
i see what it says so so volkswagen's
going to lose 155 million
in the other car volkswagen's insurance
company sure
yeah then the other ones will lose about
250 million with the cars
wow a lot of cars
folks who i can suppose spokesman
declined to comment because he can't
breathe so
our our word of caution to america if
you happen to be on craigslist in a few
months and uh
someone offers you a great deal on
lamborghini's lamborghini's on fire
that's right
hot prices this is a hot price
it will melt you
five thousand dollars you're probably
going to want to pass yeah
pay no attention to the fact that tires
are burned go back to the corolla
section and let the lamborghini section
go
oh how horrible we're laughing but i
just gotta
this breaks my heart i don't know what
else you can do i don't know what you do
you just laugh lisa's in kansas city hi
lisa how are you
hi how are you doing dave better than i
deserve how can we help
uh so i've only been listening to you
for about a month maybe two months
and uh we didn't have any debt me and my
husband
but we did have like credit cards that
were open we would just use them like
here and there to keep them open so we
closed those
and now we're in baby step three
but we were already like um saving a
retirement um ten percent for each of us
and we didn't know if we should stop
that while we're in baby step three
because i recently heard on youtube um
where you ha while you're in one two and
three you're supposed to stop your
retirement so i don't know if we should
stop doing our ten percent because we've
kind of just added a percent or two
percent there whenever we get raises and
now we're at ten percent so we didn't
know exactly what we should do if we
should stop it or just keep it there
until we get through it baby steps three
and then you know
have you done your first written budget
yes
so we've done that we've kind of
tightened up things
well
last month was our first budget okay so
it doesn't work it doesn't work very
well
first month does it
well i'm kind of like um i'm kind of
like i already had like a budget in my
mind no it wasn't
that far
you do a budget on paper it generally
doesn't work very well
yeah how much have you got how much have
you got how much are you putting towards
your emergency fund in your new budget
we're putting uh fourteen hundred
dollars a month um towards our emergency
fund what is the goal to have in there
when it's done when it's properly funded
at three to six months of expenses
seventeen thousand five hundred and
twelve dollars was what it was okay so
it's gonna take a year
yeah i've already since i was already
like saving money i already have about
six thousand oh so it won't take the
whole time because um i'm just like a
natural saver so i already have like
some money good for you guys all right
well if you're able to easily turn your
401k off and on with your hr team
then i would temporarily stop it until i
got the emergency flight done
if it's if it's a big chore it's a big
problem but the thing is this what you
focus on in life
any of us what we pay attention to what
we focus on is what we get good at
okay real simple if you focus on your
marriage you'll get better at your
marriage you focus on your kids they'll
start behaving
you know you start you focus on your
career voila you start making more money
things go you focus on your money focus
on these steps you focus on this
emergency fund that's what's going to
happen and that's the reason we tell
folks to temporarily
stop their retirement is the power of
focus
temporarily on a short-term basis which
is what we're talking about here
supersedes the power
of math
okay the power of saving i do want you
to be a big saver obviously i want you
to become wealthy i want you to have i
want you to have become a baby steps
millionaire and the way you're going to
do that you're going to fund your 401k
15 of your income going into that when
you don't have any payments and you have
a fully funded emergency fund and then
you're going to start your kids college
fund and then when you find any extra
beyond that in your
budget you're going to throw that on the
house and get the house paid off and
you'll be a millionaire doing that
that's going to work for you but the
power of focus
in a culture where we don't pay
attention to anything longer than eight
seconds if you can learn to focus you
will be vastly successful that's right
hey and as a as a
gift to joining our gang we'll send you
a copy of total money makeover it is
it's those steps you're cobbling
together on youtube it's it lays it out
for you one after the other so hang on
the line and kelly will get it sent out
to you there in kansas city
amanda's in houston hey amanda welcome
to the ramsey show hey god bless you
dave thank you what a privilege and
honor to speak to you thank you you too
darling how can we help you
um what should i
use a brokerage account to save to buy
house cash
um i don't use a brokerage account for
anything
okay yes sir i don't have a brokerage
account because the brokerage account
sounds to me like you're buying and
selling single stocks
with your advisor's help and i don't do
that
okay i might have the wrong
understanding where the brokerage i i
have a rock and then i have one that's
not retirement and i thought the not
retirement one you can use it for
anything you can you can but that would
be just you mean in a mutual fund
yeah if you have 30 seconds okay if you
just want to buy a mutual fund and save
for a house to pay cash yes that's
perfectly fine
how long is it going to take you to save
up
without the investments it probably
would have taken like at least seven
years to get like 100 000 15 000 a year
maybe
and if you're investing it in mutual
funds you would do it in what five years
um
maybe if there may be so i haven't
calculated it yet okay all right i
actually wanted to know i have the roth
and i think i'm doing too much on the
wrong i do like a thousand dollars of
total with the non-retirement and the
roth it makes 1400 a month including my
job retirement and i feel like it's too
much
a month uh i make 67 a year and i feel
like that's holding me back from saving
as much as i could save just without
investing for them you're debt-free
without saving your debt right yes sir
and you have your emergency fund in
place of three to six months
yes sir good okay
then they're pete then you're what we
call baby step 3b to save up for a house
if you can save up for a house to buy
the house in three years or less and you
want to do zero retirement for that
three years people do that sometimes
sometimes they put some in sometimes
they put 15 percent in but in no case
would we have you put more than 15
percent into retirement of your income
so 0.15 times 67 000 is your number
and uh no case do you want more than
that going in while you're getting your
home bought and paid off so hey thank
you for being a listener it's awesome
john good show today thank you
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books thanks to the booth people
they do great folks the booth folk
the book booth people it's like a new
horror movie booth folk we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
hey it's john delonie co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you